on march 25th 1965 following a
demonstration for voting rights in
montgomery alabama viola leoso was
murdered
within 24 hours four members of the ku
klux klan were arrested including gary
thomas rhode jr an undercover agent for
the fbi
history professor gary may explains what
happened in his new book the informant
this talk is 45 minutes
good evening my name is tony green i'm
the vice president for programs and
national outreach at the national
constitution center i want to welcome
you um today we are spending a lot of
time
marking the 40th anniversary of the
voting rights act we're looking through
we're looking at it through the lens of
of one woman viola liuzo
who
died in in the civil rights movement
upstairs um i'm sure all of you have
been to the
national constitution center exhibit
space we have something called the
american national tree which has the
stories of a hundred people and two of
the people on there at least are heroes
of the civil rights movement and the
battle to get to the voting rights act
and they are viola and john lewis who is
supposed to be here tonight but
unfortunately um is stuck in washington
for votes
um gary may who has
written a very readable interesting and
compelling book is with us tonight to
talk about the um fbi's role in viola
liuzo's murder the ku klux klan and the
other factors that led to why we're here
tonight gary may thank you
thank you
thank you tony thank you betsy thank you
uh everyone at the national constitution
center for inviting me here tonight and
thank all of you for coming
this has been an extraordinary summer
for americans interested in the civil
rights movement in its history
and in
the cause of justice
on june 1st the body of emmett till was
exhumed
for autopsy
i'm sure you're aware emmett till was a
young chicago teenager who went to money
mississippi
small town to visit his uncle and
cousins in the summer of 1955.
we're not entirely sure what happened
there
he may have flirted with a young 21 year
old
woman named carolyn bryant the owner of
a small grocery store
he may have also
whistled at her
we do know that
not long after that
till was kidnapped from
his uncle's home in the middle of the
night
by two men at least two men and tortured
and murdered
a cotton gin fan was tied around his
neck
and his body was thrown into the
tallahatchie river
his killers i guess hoped that the body
would rest there
forever
but as the body decomposed releasing
gases the body floated to the top
and was discovered
his killers were arrested and tried
they were carolyn bryan's husband and
his half-brother
they were found not guilty
after the jury deliberated for less than
an hour
one juror said that they would have
reached a decision even sooner but they
stopped to have a soda
the body now
has been returned to till's grave
whether it will
produce any additional information to
help the justice department which has
reopened the case
is still unclear
it's thought that there were more than
two people involved in until's murder
it's been suggested as well that perhaps
carolyn bryant was uh what was there
she is uh still alive
the other two men uh are are gone
um
so this is still an ongoing case on june
21st
edgar ray killen
a former klansman
was
convicted
of manslaughter in the deaths of three
civil rights workers in 1964.
james twain cheney michael schwerner and
andrew goodman
so this is a process now of going back
and looking at these cold cases
been going on for about a decade it's
what david halberstam calls little
nurembergs
pursuing uh those who committed terrible
crimes during the civil rights era and
trying to bring them to justice
no matter how far in the past those
crimes occurred
the forgotten case is that of viola
lyouzo
she was an extraordinary woman 39 year
old homemaker and mother of five
who answered martin luther king's call
to participate in the voting rights
march from selma to montgomery
in late march 1965.
at the conclusion of the march
she was working with a
colleague
in the in the transportation unit
and she and her colleague were stopped
at a a stop light
near the edmund pettus bridge
and discovered that a car was behind her
and as when they took off the car
followed them
the car contained four members of the
alabama ku klux klan who had spent the
day traveling around observing the
marchers observing the last day of the
march and king's speech
hoping to have an opportunity to assault
a civil rights worker
and at around 7 30 that that night
march 25th 1965 they found the target
they were looking for they followed
viola liuzzo and her companion uh
a high-speed chase ensued
finally the klansman's car pulled
around and they they shot into viola
lizo's car she was killed instantly
the car went off the road and finally
came to rest in a field
incredibly her companion was unharmed
and was able to make his way
to safety
what is extraordinary about this
case
is not only that
her sacrifice and that of others who
lost their lives during the voting
rights march
and helped to accelerate the passage of
the voting rights act what is
furthermore
more unique about the case is that
unlike the till case or the case of the
three civil rights workers or others
an fbi informant was in the car he was
one of the klansmen
and this is what my book the informant
is about it is about
gary thomas rowe tommy rowe as his
friends called him
and how he became an fbi informant
and what led him
after a five-year career as an informant
to that automobile and to the murder of
viola lyouzo
why would the fbi select
tommy rowe
as an informant
roe was
26 years old he was a self-proclaimed
hell-raiser brawler
a bouncer in a bar
someone who really had one dream and
that was to become a police officer
but he had never graduated high school
so didn't meet the minimum requirement
to become a police officer in alabama
actually applied to become a county
sheriff
falsified his application claiming that
he had graduated from high school they
caught it and and he was rejected
but roe
yearn burned really to become a police
officer
and became a cop wannabe he palled
around with the police in birmingham
partied with them
rode in their squad cars at night
and at the same time he was also
friendly with members of the klan
some of the policemen were also members
of the clan
roe
didn't want to become a klansman he
thought it was silly he said the if i
wanted to bust somebody i wouldn't have
to hide behind the hood to do it i just
go right up and do it
for the fbi he seemed to be the ideal
candidate he was young he was tough
and moreover he was extremely willing
an fbi agent visited him in the spring
of 1960
and
asked him if he'd like to serve his
country
by becoming an fbi informant
it did not take much convincing this was
the greatest moment of rose life
all he wanted to be was a police officer
and now he's being asked by the fbi to
become an informant
the agent made it clear to him that he
was not an agent and that if he broke
the law
he would be
arrested like any uh criminal but rose
saw his role as
in a more romantic way a kind of redneck
james bond who was going to become an
undercover
agent inside the clan
and that's exactly what
roe became
the fbi had instructed him
not to become involved in violence not
to be
in the planning stages of even a violent
event
but roe quickly learned that that was
impossible
and the fbi recognized it too
one of his fbi contacts said look you
may find yourself in the middle of a
riot
and you may have to throw a punch or two
and we understand
which was fine with roe because
he
enjoyed a good fight probably more than
anything
else so rowan into the clan
and quickly rose up within it
what is so extraordinary is
looking at his record during this
five-year period
and his relationship with the fbi
you would have thought that
if an informer got involved in violence
that the fbi would be concerned about
that in fact critical of that
but the opposite was true they
understood that in order to protect his
cover
and in order to convince the klansmen
that he was an authentic klansman he
would have to commit violence
furthermore
the more accepted he was he would he
would rise up even further inside the
clan group or clavern as they called it
therefore be in a position to get
important information
probably the the first dramatic incident
that roe was involved in was the attack
on the freedom riders who came to
birmingham in uh may of 1961.
in fact roe had now just
after a year in the clan
become so
important that the birmingham police
force which wanted
the freedom riders to receive a beating
turned to roe to actually set it up
so row the fbi informant became the
liaison between the birmingham police
and the ku klux klan
raw was told that bull connor the
infamous
police commissioner in birmingham wanted
the freedom riders to receive a beating
that they would always remember
and that they would have the klan would
have 15 minutes to do anything that they
wanted
there wouldn't be a cop anywhere around
after 15 minutes they should they should
get out of there
well roe was right in the thick of the
fight
attacking uh
freedom riders and also beating us a
picture in the book of him
a birmingham post-herald newspaper
photographer captured roe actually
beating
a man who wasn't a freedom rider but had
just
come to the bus station to pick up his
fiancee was in the wrong place at the
wrong time
rowe reported
to the fbi that the attack was coming
the fbi did not intervene yet to be fair
to the fbi their position was
they were not a protective organization
they were an investigative organization
that if if a federal law was being
violated then they could step in
in the case the freedom riders i i can't
accept that explanation because after
all the buses were crossing state lines
interstate travel a federally supervised
activity was involved but at least that
was the bureau's justification were they
angry at roe
for what he had done that day as as was
illustrated on the front page of the
birmingham post herald absolutely not
in fact roe received a bonus of 150
dollars
and
washington was informed by the special
agent in charge of the birmingham field
office that roe was the
most active the most intelligent and the
most reliable informant they had inside
the clan
row spent the next several years
in this kind of activity
attacking
blacks civil rights workers
and again the fbi
not only accepted this but really
encouraged this
there is some evidence too
that roe may have been involved in
perhaps the most
infamous act of the 1960s the bombing of
the 16th street baptist church in
birmingham in september of 1963. the
evidence is is a little sketchy here but
it seems that all of roe's friends
knew that a bomb was being planted
apparently the klansmen thought the bomb
would go off in the middle of the night
when the
building was vacant of course they were
not very good bomb makers
and the bomb went off the following
morning
tragically killing uh four young girls
everyone knew that that a bomb was being
planted and roe later claimed that he
had no knowledge of it i just don't find
that credible
roe
knew all the men involved
in fact throughout 1962 and 1963 when
bombs went off in birmingham so
frequently that
the city became known as bombingham
roe was always the first one to report a
bombing to his fbi contact
and later when roe was being
investigated by the justice department
his fbi contacts were asked didn't you
think of peculiar that roe would be the
first one to report a bombing that
perhaps he had something to do with it
and
the agents would reply oh no we just
thought he was being a good citizen
all of this then brought roe to
march
1965 and the voting rights march
that night he was in the car
he uh later said that he did not fire
his gun
and when he uh later after the shooting
and roe was able to get away from
uh the klansmen he immediately called
his fbi
contact
they met in the middle of the night
in an empty parking lot in in the middle
of a rainstorm
the agent examined roe's gun concluded
it had not been fired
and pretty much accepted roe's version
of events that they had
happened on these uh lisa and her
companion chased them down
shot in the car
and and perhaps killed her
the next day
the klansmen were arrested it was an
extraordinary moment lyndon johnson
had become so interested in the case
that when he first heard about
the murder
on the night of march 25th that he
immediately called j edgar hoover
and wanted information
and he continued to call
the bureau throughout the night
then he was told the following morning
by j edgar hoover that
they had the fbi had one of their men
inside the car
hoover misrepresented
roe's
role he said that rhode did not have a
gun
and that you know he had just
been
along for the ride and was not involved
johnson was was very excited that the
murderers were
identified and he announced their arrest
over nationwide television
it broke into the regularly scheduled
broadcasting and
president johnson and jedi hoover and
attorney general nicholas katzenbach
were there and johnson announced the
arrest
of the klansmen
at that point
he he included gary thomas rowe as one
of the
suspects but
roe was not uh arrested he was not in
jail
he was in fact working with the fbi in
building a case against his fellow
klansmen
roe quickly made a deal with the justice
department in fact he demanded it
clearly his testimony in court would be
absolutely critical he was the only
eyewitness
to
the tragedy
and so rome made a number of demands
he wanted his ex-wife and children
relocated to another state to protect
them
he wanted a new identity he wanted a
lifetime career in law enforcement
and the fbi accepted each one of his
demands
roe testified against the klansmen
at
their
trials
one of the clansmen died of a heart
attack before going to trial
the other two
were found not guilty by local alabama
courts
eventually however
they were tried for having violated her
civil rights
and found guilty in each of those trials
roe was the star
witness
roe was rewarded for his testimony he
was given
ten thousand dollars in cash and told by
uh his agents that jedi hoover thought
he was one of the great americans
alive
and that
this
money was from the director
and that roe would be
relocated to san diego california where
he would become a deputy u.s marshal
so you would think that
this again would sort of be one of uh
a happy moment for roe
but
he could change his name and he was
given a new name but he could not change
his character
the death of viola luzo was of course
devastating for her family
the family
literally fell apart the children
left school
one became involved in some petty crime
another
dependence on drugs and alcohol
one actually
moved to alabama
not far from where his mother was killed
in fact he is still living in alabama to
this day
rose time as a deputy us marshall was
very short
as i say he could change his name but he
could not change his character
he got involved in lots of fights he
liked to
pull his gun on people
he uh he enjoyed stopping police
officers and uh and and pulling his gun
on them
finally the
u.s marshals service just
had it with roe and he was
fired he wandered around
the country for a couple of years doing
some private detective work
and during this period kind of built up
tremendous and i think incorrect
animosity toward the justice department
and the fbi blaming them for what had
happened to him
in truth the fbi had had been pretty
good to him i had rescued him from
some ordinary life as a machinist in
1960 and given him this this fabulous
career
finally roll went public he appeared
before
the church committee in december of
1975.
the church committee was investigating
uh the excesses of the fbi and the cia
during the 1960s and 1970s
and roe told his story
he talked about
the attack on the freedom riders
and how the bureau had known
it was coming and had done nothing
talked about
getting information from the clan
the best way he said was sleeping with
clan wives
and
i think he said he slept with 40 or 50
clan wives during his time as an fbi
informant
a tremendous exaggeration in fact after
roe testified about this a number of
clan wives in birmingham
got very upset
one
actually went to the press and said my
daughter is asking me did you sleep with
tommy rowe and i didn't and i've talked
to my friends and they say they didn't
so i don't know you know i don't know
what what he's talking about
roe became a celebrity
as a result of his appearance before the
church committee by the way he wore a
hood
to
disguise his identity
but as i say he became famous now
he was offered a book contract
and he he wrote his memoir or actually
he he allowed the memoir to be written
by a ghost writer
the memoir was bought by columbia
pictures and turned into a
made made-for-tv movie
which was shown later in the 70s
he was on the today show
and you know pretty much made made the
circuit
the liusa family was of course stunned
to learn of rose activities uh as an fbi
informant
they thought initially that he'd been a
hero you know he had he had come out of
of of hiding as an informant testified
publicly in the number of trials
including the federal trial but now they
learned that he'd been involved in the
attack on the freedom riders possibly
involved in the bombing of the 16th
street baptist church
and they came to believe that roe had
actually fired the shot that killed
their mother
so they launched a wrongful death
lawsuit in the 1980s against
the fbi
i'm not going to tell you how it turned
out because i don't want to spoil
your reading
pleasure hopefully
the story that i tell in the book
and rose experience i think raises some
extremely important questions
as i was working on the book the tragedy
of 9 11 occurred
and the president began to speak about
the need for more human intelligence
more
informants to penetrate
terrorist groups
and it seemed to me in in researching
and then writing about tommy rowe
that
using informants was a very dangerous
business as i've indicated in order to
protect their cover in order to convince
their fellow terrorists
that they were authentic they had to be
involved in violence
and rose experience showed that the fbi
had encouraged this and was in in effect
an accessory to uh these various crimes
and it seems to me that if we try to do
that in the war against terrorism
we might well
achieve the same kinds of results
informants
operated by the fbi or cia actually
committing the very violence that they
are supposed to prevent
so the uzo story the roe story i think
is is very important
and
i'm hoping that at least the book will
help to get this story out and it will
become part of the debate about how to
fight the war against terrorism
thank you i'd be happy to take your
questions
[Applause]
yes did the uh
did fbi informants actually prevent any
kind of violent crimes
by this method yes and in fact uh to be
fair to roe uh he did on at least one
occasion
roe in 1962
learned of an assassination plot against
reverend fred shuttlesworth who was the
martin luther king of birmingham
and roe passed this information on to
his fbi contact because raw was actually
one of the men selected to assassinate
the reverend shuttlesworth
the bureau paused they were always
afraid of doing something that might
reveal
rose identity
but a man's life was at stake here so
they finally decided they had to do
something so they met with reverend
shuttlesworth warned him against
going to a
airport restaurant where uh
shuttlesworth was going to try to
desegregate it
because that's where the assassination
was going to take place solosworth was
very grateful he didn't go there that
night and and he's still alive today
so occasionally the fbi would act on the
information and would prevent violence
but in rose case uh it seems to have
been uh rare that the bureau actually
prevented
violence from from occurring
i wish i could be more confident about
the thousands of other people who became
informants inside the clan
i can't because historians journalists
interested in this subject can't get
access to
informant files at the fbi
they are exempt from the freedom of
information act
uh the fbi guards those those records uh
you know very very carefully for obvious
reasons for what it reveals about
their complicity in in in so many events
i was fortunate because
in the in the case of of the lyouzo
murder
and the later wrongful death lawsuit the
liuso family attorney received
rose informant files from the fbi
through the discovery process and the
the the lawyer dean rob was kind enough
to give me access to those records
so at least i can i can tell you one
case where actually prevent violence but
i can't speak about the thousands of
others
sir
is rose still alive and if so did you
also have contact with him while you
were preparing your phone ro died in in
1998
he spent his last years in savannah
georgia where he was was born
he working for a private detective firm
it is said that he died of of natural
causes
although i
managed to locate one of rose
children from a very early marriage
and she told me that
she thought her father had been murdered
and the story she told me was was so
incredible
he'd been working as a private detective
he'd come across some evidence that
a savannah politician had been involved
in a murder
and in order to keep him quiet
he had been murdered
i i try to to trace this down you won't
find the story in the book my editor
said well you you can't prove it so you
better not include it in the book
uh i did talk with an investigative
reporter at the savannah morning news
and he looked into the story
and is still looking into it
his conclusion is that roe probably died
of a heart attack but there's some odd
things he's discovered about roe's death
the autopsy report is missing
should it should still exist
the night that roe died a number of
police and
county sheriffs appeared at his house
more than would be there
in in the case of a normal uh
fatality
so the journalist he too can't can't uh
you know go on record about what he's
found he thinks roe may have in fact
been involved in something and that had
records and that the police were there
to get those records did they know his
true identity
uh just about everybody did in town
although roe uh in his last years uh
went under a pseudonym thomas neil moore
the neil was was from the first name of
his favorite fbi uh handler uh neil
shanahan
who actually lives in a suburb of
philadelphia
so roe really didn't try to to hide uh
who he was uh he he became a kind of
local character
yes ma'am
did you have any contact
with viola lyouzo's son who moved to
alabama and what
prompted him to go there
well
the uh he
her son tom
was probably the closest of her children
closer to her mother than anyone else
and had become very very
emotionally troubled after the death
and
i couldn't contact him i couldn't find
him
i'm not sure that the family knows
precisely where he is
today
i did talk to
one of her other sons
and this son
joined the michigan militia in the 1980s
after the failure of the of the lawsuit
and i spoke to um her daughter mary
uh who was wonderful and gave me a very
frank and candid interview about her
mother
yes sir
on balance having listened to you now on
balance i'm not sure did this man do
more good than harm
i'm not sure myself um although i really
should take a position i think on this
i would have to conclude that he
probably did more harm
than good
the reverend shuttlesworth might
disagree with me but
certainly as i say the the the
information that he passed along
uh was so rarely acted upon by the fbi
that um it just does not seem to have
been
worth
the trouble that was caused and in fact
roe himself
in later years said that he thought it
was probably unnecessary to infiltrate
the klan to put informants inside the
clan he said
there are probably about a dozen people
inside the clan who were the most
dangerous and if the fbi had kept him
under surveillance
so much could have been prevented but it
wasn't really necessary uh to to
infiltrate the klan
what was so interesting is you know we
have this perception of what the clan is
like and
this clan group that i studied which was
considered among the most dangerous was
a kind of combination of the keystone
cops and the manson family uh i mean
they were capable of of the silliest
sorts of things
yet at the same time a few of them
were vicious
killers
yes
it doesn't sound like the fbi has much
of a good history until today
well again uh i think a historian has
got to look at the entire record here
and in fact in in my research
what i found was that the
the the field agents especially the the
the major case inspectors who were
called in after uh mrs liuzo was killed
uh the ones who um
search for the killers of cheney
schwerner and goodman
these were first-rate people uh they
weren't uh racist like j edgar hoover
was
they were not out to destroy the civil
rights movement like jager hoover was
they were serious investigators
and they worked very hard
and they're not well known to the public
so we have to be fair i think the higher
up one went in in the bureau uh you
found the more serious problems
especially uh in in hoover himself
yes
you called um
hoover a racist and so can did your
research reveal
can you talk a little bit about what
your research may have revealed in terms
of relationship between lbj and also
hoover were there any nuggets that you
found and did lbj were they using each
other for different purposes uh
it's a wonderful question um
we have now a tremendous
and rich resource in in the lbj tapes
which are available to to all citizens
here's lbj with the bark off uh he had
tape
machinery on all his telephones and and
just all over the place uh
and
you you really hear him uh expressing
himself very frankly what's fascinating
is if you look at the conversations
between hoover and lbj
you discover that that not only was lbj
taping hoover hoover was taping lbj
they had an interesting relationship
they've known each other for a long time
and after all johnson first went to
washington in 1931
when hoover himself was was a young
director of the fbi
um
for a time they actually i think lived
across the street from one another
lbj also recognized that hoover was a
man that you you couldn't cross
uh i suppose on the one hand he would
have loved to have gotten rid of him
finally fired him i mean hoover was you
know the longest serving
director of the fbi in history and
probably one of the the longest serving
federal bureaucrats
itself
but he couldn't johnson couldn't kennedy
had thought of doing that but he knew
that hoover had so much stuff in his
files
about president kennedy about lyndon
johnson too
lyndon johnson was as much uh
a womanizer as jfk was and and those
records were in fbi files i didn't see
any of that uh
some of huber's most sensitive files
were burned by his private secretary
after his death
uh i think that they did use one another
certainly uh
hoover wanted johnson to protect him
from his critics to allow him as johnson
did to let his empire
grow
as it did
and at the same time johnson used hoover
knowing that he was
at least in the 60s one of the most
respected men in the country it's only
later of course that we we now have
revelations about what hoover was all
about but i think i know i'm speaking
for myself uh every boy growing up at
one time or another at least in the time
i was growing up wanted to become an fbi
agent
and not long before tommy rowe became an
informant one of the most popular films
in the country was the fbi story with
jimmy stewart
so um
so we now know more about hoover and the
johnson hoover relationship is is a
fascinating one great question
yes ma'am
did you ever get the feeling that
roe really needed to be
rescued from himself
it seems that the fbi we're really
creating more of a monster
because
it sounds as if a person with such a
personality it sounds like he might have
really been very very power hungry
and
the fbi was really feeding his ego
well the fbi uh did feed his ego and
they wanted him
to to rise up within the klan in order
to get more and more important
information
yet they recognized that he was someone
who could be very difficult to control
and again what was fascinating in
examining these records as roe became
such an important informant
and his contact agents would would
retire from the bureau
and their replacements would be uh
selected
the agents actually auditioned for roe
uh you know they were they recognized
how important role was and their own
careers as fbi agents were dependent on
their ability to cultivate and create
informants so you have a case of of
someone retiring his rose contact agent
selecting his successor and the
successor saying well i sure hope he's
going to like me you know i i think
he'll like me we've met we've had coffee
and i think we'll get along fine so it's
it's a fascinating relationship uh it
was one of the most interesting things i
think uh in the book you know the
relationship between an informant and
his handler this this kind of very
strange sort of tension um
and in some cases a very close
relationship
when rose's first contact agent retired
uh in uh in 1961 he was broken up i mean
he was he was just uh
falling apart and he wanted to quit
but his success the the agent's
successor said no tommy you've got to
stay you're doing a great job for the
country and of course i'm not sure was
entirely serious about leaving uh the
informant world because it was so much
fun
but he was very disturbed that his you
know his first agent was going to go off
and leave him
yes sir will you comment on
how the fbi's undercover activities
compared to other spy organizations that
are undercover well
a wonderful question which i i wish i
could answer
i indicated earlier that
informant files are
off limits to historians that they're
exempt from the freedom of information
act so historians can't get their hands
on informant files i was lucky because
in the leisure case it was a wrongful
death lawsuit and the fbi had to give
their files to
the user family attorney who gave me
access to them
so it's hard for me to answer that um
i i think it's it's probably similar
though to
spies who are run for example by the by
the c i a
or even in other
international intelligence services
they have to pick these people who
they can control
yet they have to be
have a certain strength and power to to
live this kind of life and it takes a
person i think who's a little on the odd
side
as roe was to uh to live a kind of
double life some people i guess those
who are drawn to the secret world of
international intelligence or domestic
intelligence
love it they love that excitement of
pretending to be something that they're
not
i wish i had the records to confidently
answer that question it's a great one
yes ma'am
you said that there were
or that rose said that if they uh kind
of kept track of 12 people within the
clan
uh that would have been okay and they
wouldn't have needed informants but i'm
trying to understand how they would have
known those 12 people if they didn't
have informants
and where i'm going with this is i'm
going to the issue of terrorism now
where if they're saying oh we really
need informants and people are saying
well we don't need informants and some
people are saying we don't need
informants and they're saying well if we
could just track down x number of people
you know that would give us insight so
could you kind of answer the question
about 12 in the clan um take it to the
terrorists yes yes um
in one of the reviews of my book uh the
reviewer
said that i was opposed to all
informants and and that's not true i
think it was a misreading of what i had
written
um it seemed to me that it was more
dangerous to recruit informants from the
outside and then to put them
inside the clan or any other terrorist
group
because
the terrorists the klansmen become
immediately suspicious about this person
and roe in fact was challenged several
times accused of being an fbi informant
and he was able to either fight or talk
his way
out of it
in the case of the clan and i think it's
much
easier
identifying who were the most dangerous
people than it is in in the world now of
of international terrorism
in the case of the clan it was obvious i
mean there was one
one man named robert chambliss who was
eventually convicted of of being the
main bomber
in the 16th street baptist church case
everybody knew
dynamite bob that was his nickname
uh i mean he'd been around birmingham
for 20 years as this you know in and out
of jail in in time protected
actually by bill connery he worked for
the birmingham police force for a time
uh so it was obvious
you didn't need uh to put somebody
inside the clan to answer your question
more specifically in in the case for
example of the mississippi burning case
in 1964
the fbi was able to solve that case
by offering money to klansmen
who could identify the killers lead the
fbi to the location of the bodies
it seemed to me that's the effective way
to go about this to use money or
whatever you have to to turn people who
are already members
of terrorist groups
easy to do i think with the clan
but very very difficult with terrorist
groups of the kind that we're now
dealing with these are obviously
committed
ideologues who
um are quite willing to give their life
for their their cause
yes
once
once they had evidence
from this guy that bull connor
was operating with the clan
what reason was them
what reason was there for them not to
use that evidence against him
um
they
had no position
regarding conor um
some agents like connor
some agents had um
grown up in the south
some had gone to the south married
southern women and tended to be kind of
sympathetic to segregation
and didn't have any problem at all with
with conor i couldn't find any evidence
that that uh that hoover you know
disliked conor um i mean they probably
had a lot in common you know they were
both a tough law and order men
did i answer your question i'm not not
sure i did i guess in practical terms
you probably did i mean law and order
men don't real law and order men don't
allow tell people you can commit a crime
for 15 minutes
i know i don't know
but okay i think we have time for one
more question
yes ma'am
other than being a fascinating
historical
story do you see
uh any of this being relevant to the
problems of today and i don't just mean
the terrorists but also the far right
militias
well i think it it does um
primarily again in terms of how do you
get information about these groups how
do you develop informants do you put
them inside the klan or other terrorist
groups or militia groups do you try to
turn people who are already inside so i
think that at least i hope the book does
speak
to some of these problems
but it's also i think a terrific story
i'm primarily a storyteller and
always wanted to
to write in a way that's accessible to
readers there's no point it seems to me
for a historian to write for the six or
seven other scholars who are in the
field and you have to have an audience
out there like all of you good people so
that's what i've tried to do thank you
thank you
gary may is author of un-american
activities the trials of william
remington
and china's scapegoat the diplomatic
ordeal of john carter vincent
his latest the informant is published by
yale university press on the web at
yalebooks.com